Carl Sagan the great communicator said
it best the Earth is nothing but a moat
of dust floating on a Sunbeam
today we'll jump right in and discover
the three ways that dust plays a role in
your life in ways you never knew and the
third one will absolutely blow you away
let's go any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic
thank you
Shakespeare The Bard had a way with
words in Hamlet the protagonist asked
the question to me what is the
quintessence of dust
I'm no Shakespearean actor but but that
powerful human beings are made of dust
and today we're going to explore the
three major ways that dust plays a role
in your life and even in your body
itself before we get into the three
vital ways it does plays a role in your
life clean up the dust on your index
finger and click the thumbs up button I
bet you're thinking that dust only
bothers you it only gets on the cover of
dust jackets it only follows your
toddler around as she makes her way
throughout the house it gets in the back
of your car and people write on it wash
me what a pain universe is filled with
exotic minutia tiny particles Elementary
composite forces and Fields that make up
the cosmos on this channel we've
explored the Dynamics of these lightest
scene particles like neutrinos all the
way to Dark Matter particles that we
have not yet seen and don't know for
sure even if they exist we've explored
the Perpetual nuclear explosions that we
call Stars how they light up the cosmos
and sometimes in a violent fireworks
display becomes supernovae that scatter
there to treat us throughout the cosmos
and without that very process we
wouldn't be here explaining the
properties of dust we live in a vast and
Mysterious Universe without dust you
wouldn't be here we all wouldn't be here
we live on a rocky planet which the
famous Communicator Carl Sagan called a
pale blue dot
in this image commanded by him made by
the Voyager 1 spacecraft on Valentine's
Day 1990. the very planet that we're
sitting on and floating through space on
is a giant rock which is basically a
giant dust grain the byproducts of
carbon nitrogen silicon and the
molecules made of them clumping together
to make an enormous Ball but it goes
deeper literally into your veins the
second way that dust affects your life
is that the hemoglobin molecule in your
blood gives it the red color which then
when deoxygenated becomes blue is
reliant on the capture of an iron atom
that iron atom came from the Supernova
that produced the material that the
planet is made of and in particular made
the iron core that we've discussed in
this video produces no net energy is an
endothermic reaction that doesn't allow
the nuclear fusion process to keep on
current
Third Way that dust affects you is that
it obscures our view of the cosmos
making it seem that our galaxy and even
the universe is somehow centered on us
we've explored that in the great debate
videos and it may play a role in the
eventual ability or inability of
cosmologists like my colleagues in the
Simon's Observatory it may limit our
ability to Glimpse the very aftershocks
of the Big Bang itself which we call the
inflationary universe
dust is truly the quintessence of our
existence we've known about dust in the
cosmos for ages as far back as the
ancient Incan astronomers of South
America who at the time saw not the
Luminous dots of light that we use as
constellations they use the dark nebulae
priced primarily of dust as their
fortune telling objects these
astronomical devices in their zodiac are
very different from ours you have
features like a rat a camel a llama and
even my favorite zodiac sign the
umbilicus of the Llama what's your sign
and they weren't far off in ascribing
lifelike properties to the dark Dusty
globules that's because dust is the
substance of which our Cosmos is formed
we also have seen brilliant displays no
pun intended of dark Dusty columns in
this image taken from the James Webb
Space Telescope just this year of the
Pillars of Creation a
harboring perhaps trillions of planetary
fragments within it the universe teams
with dust and that dust could be vital
as Christian to do have called it but it
isn't always easy to see actually most
of the time dust is hard to see it's
faint it obscures it blocks and it
prevents light coming from Elsewhere for
centuries it was seen as a cosmic
nuisance getting in the way of distant
Celestial targets dimming their light
making it more red and also causing it
to become polarized dust is the
foundation of our universe literally the
foundation of our planet what starts as
Tiny dust grades gathers together in
what's called protoplanetary accretion
forming a protoplanetary disk in this
disc tiny bits of rock and Ice clumped
together making so-called planetesimals
these can be just a few meters to
kilometers in width when they get big
enough they gather more mass and they
get packed Tighter and Tighter warming
up and in fact the core of our Earth can
also be molten because of the incredible
pressure of tens of trillions of
kilograms worth of matter compacted into
a relatively small less than ten
thousand kilometer radius ball that we
call our home planet
[Music]
there are at least as many planets in
the Milky Way as there are stars some
solar systems like the trappist-1 system
even have a multitude of planets very
close to our Earth existing in What's
called the habitable zone where water
can be in liquid form and they exist in
a region close enough to the host star
of that Stellar system that they could
Harbor life in liquid oceans in the
grand context of the universe planets
like ours are really a dime a dozen but
dust but again just like dust that
doesn't make it insignificant until
recently Cosmic dust was nothing more
than a cosmic dirty windshield obscuring
and blocking our viewing the Stars
but it's always been a chimerical
challenge for astronomers to deal with
and now we've turned our attention to
dust itself and some people's entire
astronomical careers are built on the
study of dust and that that long
tradition dating back to the original
astronomer Galileo he was deceived by
Dusty deluge
he saw the Pleiades asterism as a as a
cloud that was actually in his mind
comprised of innumerable Stars he
convinced himself that if he had a big
enough telescope he could resolve those
cloudy blurry blotches into individual
resolve stars but he can't because that
is a reflection nebula that surrounds
the Pleiades as shown here the star
merapi in the lower left quadrant of the
Pleiades as you view it on the sky is a
reflection nebula comprised primarily of
carbon nanoparticles that act like
little mirrors and by studying the
spectrum of the Dust pairing it to the
host star the star nearby maripi
astronomers saw that they had exactly
the same spectral Behavior the dust was
acting like little mirrors merely just
reflecting the light from the Star not
producing light and not behaving like
little stars themselves either a century
or so later William Herschel and his
sister Caroline identified the disc like
shape of our galaxy using dust and
thanks to how easily it can block what's
behind it he was duped into thinking our
son was actually near the center of the
Galaxy
which was ironic given that Galileo had
figuratively displaced the Earth from
being the center of the universe to
merely the third dust devil from the Sun
then in the 1900s came Harlow shapley
who thought the Milky Way was Far bigger
than it actually was thanks to dust
by the dim appearance of distant Stars
globular clusters thinking that their
dimness was due to their distance
falling off as the inverse Square law
when actually it was dust in our galaxy
that dimmed the light and the stars that
he was looking at were actually much
closer it turned out by using the
positions of globular clusters and
triangulating their positions we could
see where the center of the Milky Way's
mass and therefore its star
concentration was highest and that the
Earth was actually located orbiting
around the Sun some two-thirds of the
way out on one of the many spiral arms
of the Milky Way galaxy
one of which has tremendous amounts of
dust within it and now dust is impacting
our view of the cosmos at its earliest
phases not because dust was created back
at the origin of the universe but
because dust can obscure it and that's
the third way that dust impacts our
understanding of the universe you've
heard many times in this channel the
concept of the Multiverse in many
interviews ranging from will Kinney to
opponents of the Multiverse in
conversations with Neil Turok the
question is how can we observe the
presence of the Multiverse some say if
we detect inflationary generated B mode
polarization from primordial
gravitational waves that suffuse the
cosmos we would have indirect evidence
for our Multiverse in fact that was the
very claim back in 2014 when the bicep
II experiment that I participated in and
is the subject of my first book losing
the Nobel Prize that instrument using
detectors just like this these are
superconducting transition Edge sensor
barometers whose resistance changes as
they're cool down or warmed up by
microwave background radiation nation
and they're polarized too just like
Cosmic polarizing sunglasses in front of
each detector this array and three
others like it were cooldowns in your
absolute zero using this instrument we
claimed that we had glimpsed the spark
that ignited the Big Bang the so-called
inflationary Epoch our standard model of
the Big Bang has gaps in it lacune that
incorporates the creation of the
universe all the way evolving till today
we've talked about inflation as a
candidate model for such an inciting
incident and there are many astronomers
believe that inflation is the only way
in which the universe could have started
and could comatant with inflation comes
to Multiverse so to Glimpse evidence for
the Multiverse we have to contend with
obscuring signals like dust for example
as described in losing the Nobel Prize
less than a year after bicep 2's
historic announcement on March 17 2014
we made an announcement at Harvard
Center for astrophysics claiming that we
had detected B mode polarization The
Smoking Gun evidence for inflation
in early 2015 working alongside the
Planck satellite team we were able to
demonstrate we had made a mistake we had
not made a detection of the faint bemode
polarization produced by inflationary
generated gravitational waves instead we
detected non-primordial but
astrophysical Galactic grains of dust
which mimic the b-mode polarization
signal to a t we were deceived and duped
by Dusty delusions we didn't make a
blunder we didn't leave the lens cap on
the telescope and in fact the instrument
continues in a fourth Incarnation called
bicep array which is making the world
leading measurements of the v-mode
polarization signal so we're still on
the hunt for this if we can get past the
Dust
so we need to do two experiments dust is
what's called a systematic contaminant
it's an error in the system the system
being the telescope plus the Earth plus
our Cosmic location within the dusty
spiral arms of the Milky Way galaxy
we have to do a separate experiment to
get rid of systematic errors we can't
just keep measuring the same thing over
and over again and getting smaller and
smaller error bars we have to dedicate a
separate experiment or a component of
the existing experiment just to looking
at dust so what we measure are the total
signal s is equal to the cosmic signal C
plus the dust signal which is
astrophysical but not cosmological we
measure the total signal and then with a
separate component of the experiment in
this case a high frequency channel of
the instrument using the same type of
detector system
we can look only at the dusty to treat
us and then we can subtract a very high
Precision measurement of D from the
signal that we measured above leaving us
just with the cosmic signal C
and that should have the closest
approximation to the true amount of
primordial gravitational wave energy as
we can measure we're doing that with the
Simon's Observatory and the bicep array
team is doing it as well so just as much
as Cosmic dust creates it destroys it
can deceive it can delude us into seeing
what we want to see thus throughout all
of modern astronomy has been the Janus
face spoiler savior Creator and
concealer the founder and flaw mixer of
astronomical aspirations it's Central to
the cycles of the cosmos it flows
through all of our veins and
understanding and accounting for dust is
at the Forefront of cosmology and
astrophysics today
so with a dose of what Mahatma Gandhi
called humility Cosmic humility the
Seeker after truth must be humbler than
the dust seeing that the dust could
crush him rather than walking on it and
crushing dust as most of us do in our
daily lives astronomers of the future
can deal with dust
[Music]
and having the requisite humility if
you'd like to learn more about The
Cutting Edge search for inflation click
here and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
thank you